we have a voicemail number and that
number is 2192 David P here is a very
important and Powerful reaction to the
arrest of Donald Trump take a listen to
this
what about Hillary's emails
all right thanks bye I know uh that this
is tongue-in-cheek in all seriousness
what a backfire what about Hillary was
the criminal and Biden's a criminal and
Obama's a criminal and Trump is not a
criminal and yet Trump is the one who is
getting arrested and indicted at least
once if not many many more times as we
might see in the next six to eight weeks
what about Hillary's emails that is a
really great question we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today
quietly Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
has legalized permitless concealed carry
in Florida what
yes secondly we are at a 16-year high in
traffic deaths why we will discuss and
thirdly Paris is Banning those electric
rental scooters
I actually have a lot to say about this
and the whole rental scooter thing in
general so we're going to talk about all
of that on today's bonus show get
instant access by signing up at
joinpakman.com